Tim Allen success on the stand-up
circuit led to him starring in the
long-running sitcom home improvement
which gave him nationwide fame he
eventually went on to star as the voice
of Buzz Lightyear in Disney beloved Toy
Story movies and as Santa in the santa
claus franchise his comic talent and
everyman charm made it seem like he was
poised to become a major movie star but
over the past decade he's almost
disappeared from the big screen here is
a look at why you won't see too many
movies starring Tim Allen anymore his
shtick is old Tim Allen has always been
identified with a very specific type of
character the ordinary politically
incorrect man man that made him a big
hit in the 80s and 90s on television but
hasn't translated to modern movie
audiences which according to the NBA's
research are attended by more women than
men which doesn't quite suit Allen style
the bathroom has everything including
the brand-new lazy bowl reclining floor
so it's not really a surprise that Alan
has stuck with television and said where
he can still safely target that same
male demographic third in line even when
Alan was at his absolute hottest he was
rarely anyone's first choice for film
roles for instance the Santa Clause was
reportedly written with Bill Murray in
mind when he passed a long-standing
rumor said it was offered to Chevy Chase
before finally going to Alan and he
allegedly was third in line for Buzz
Lightyear to with Pixar pitching the
role to both Jim Carrey and Billy
Crystal first considering how difficult
it was for him to get good roles even
when he was at the height of his
popularity it's no wonder he seems to
have even fewer opportunities now big
screen disappointment while the toy
story and Santa Clause franchises have
both been big hits most of Allen's other
movies have been either critical or
box-office disappointment and usually
both his most recent efforts like crazy
on the outside and three geezers had
brief or non-existent theatrical run and
his filmography is littered with movies
like jungle 2 jungle wild hogs and
Christmas with the Kranks olive which
currently sits below 20% on Rotten
Tomatoes even when critics like his film
they don't always hit it big with fans
the martial arts drama red bell for
instance grossed less than 2.5 million
dollars despite favorable reviews and
while Galaxy Quest has become a true
called classic with many science fiction
fans counting it as one of their
favorites it only made a modest 71
million dollars against a 45 million
dollar budget respectable but hardly
enough to change Allen's reputation as
someone whose success comes from its
franchises instead of the other way
around
played out both of Allen's big
franchises seem to be pretty much played
out artistically if not financially
every installment of the Santa Claus
trilogy got worse reviews and made less
money than the previous one and while
Toy Story 4 is in production it seems
kind of like a cash grab considering Toy
Story 3 clearly was intended as a series
coda even if it becomes the massive
box-office hit everyone expects that
probably won't translate to new film
roles for Allen though it will mean he
gets to milk the series for even more
voice work in Toy Story shorts made 40
movies video games and rides of Disney
World hey money is money family-friendly
flops Allen primarily achieved fame
through family-friendly comedy on home
improvement and he helped cement
family-friendly as his big-screen genre
with Toy Story however a number of other
all-ages projects fizzled in 2006 for
example Allen appeared in three movies
the shaggy dog Santa Claus 3 and zoom
while the shaggy dog and Santa Claus
three at least earned their budgets back
at the box office
zoom was a complete disaster and all
three were critically panned to the
point where Allen earned a worst actor
nomination at the Razzies for his
corrective incompetence max Freddie
unfriendly you are a sad strange little
man and you have my pity farewell
works well with others Allen works best
as part of it ensemble cast
for example his portrayal of Buzz
Lightyear wouldn't be half as charming
without having Tom Hanks his woody to
bounce off of or without his interaction
with the rest of the colorful cast his
critically beloved turn and Galaxy Quest
was so successful in large part because
he was playing off of some very heavy
hitters including Sigourney Weaver and
Alan Rickman come on got my crew I'm not
a commander even wild hogs a critical
pariah was financially successful
primarily because it also featured
Martin Lawrence John Travolta and
William H Macy if you were creating a
recipe for a hit movie alan is less of a
key ingredient and more of a condiment
or garnish busy TV career of course
perhaps the most obvious reason that Tim
Allen isn't regularly starring in movies
is that he well just doesn't have to in
2010 he tried his hand at directing was
crazy on the outside when that flopped
he simply returned to CD in 2011 with
last-man-standing
a sort of spiritual reboot of home
improvement where Allen brings his
blue-collar alpha-male schtick into the
21st century he's a man's man
but lately he's realizing what happened
in men he's not a man's world anymore
the show which Alan executive produces
as well as stars in has been critically
panned from the beginning and yet it
shows absolutely no signs of slowing
down
with six seasons as of the making of
this video with Last Man Standing
offering steady work for steady ratings
we're guessing Alan isn't eager to run
away from his small screen success any
time soon thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]